[Music]
congratulations I haven't seen you since
the baby
have you gotten some rest sir yeah I
mean my boobs are not functional in that
sense so I was getting more rest yeah
I'm ready I'm excited to see his new
energy on the show because you know he's
got other things more important to worry
about he could finally come on to the
show and really enjoy the process
changing him coming at ya absolutely you
could see just how you know shy is
ultimately you know the Apple to his eye
like he's he is the his priority is the
only thing he thinks about it you know
and the person he becomes alive when
he's around as his son bringing the baby
along to I don't know depends on who
needs votes more I think he will totally
use the baby for the votes
I already told I said listen you know I
get the dibs because you know she has
the sympathy with like a baby mama
coming back and all that when you we
just need something yeah Val wants to
use the baby for some self-promotion too
so it's not weird no I already told him
I'm not gonna pimp out his baby for
Low's okay not right Alice might be
using the baby to pick up some some
chick on the dance oh yeah I mean he's
moved on from the puppies and you know
Bulldogs now it's the baby thing
if you changing a lot of diapers not
even one attempt at even like hey maybe
you know I want to change something just
to like gonna be part of the fam no not
even a little bit I'm definitely an
absentee uncle but you know what we're
gonna be homies one day and I'm not
trying to like you know he's gonna be
really mad at me
when he grows up is like man how dare
you see me in that situation so
vulnerable and I'm just trying to save
that you know
I don't want to ruin our future
friendship
[Music]
you